OAuth 2.0 Is a widely used authorization framework
that enables web and desktop applications,
as well as mobile devices to obtain specified
constrained access to user accounts on an HTTP service.
OAuth 2.0 defines four roles, resource owner,
resource server, authorization server which can be the same as the resource server,
client in our case the FHIR app.
The resource server host the protected information.
The authorization server verifies the identity of the prospective user of
that information and then issues access tokens to the application.
And OAuth 2.0 scope,
specifies the level of access such as read or write that the application is requesting.
In the case of SMART on FHIR,
the scope might specify what FHIR resources can be accessed for
a specified patient and how much of CRUD the app can perform on those resources.
In SMART on FHIR,
when a EHR user launches an app,
he gets a launch request notification,
the app asks for the permissions it needs using OAuth scopes such as patient/*.
read. In the case of a launch within an EHR charting session,
the scope patient/*.read refers to
the patient whose chart is in use at the time of the launch.
The term for this is in context and
this request only makes sense within a charting session.
The app does not yet know who that patient is when it requests the scope,
it learns that from the access token response where
the patient property will provide the FHIR patient resource ID.
These so called launch parameters are an extremely important capability of SMART on FHIR.
As you know, tools such as clinical decision support have
existed for decades but have not found wide use.
To coin a small pun,
providing this context literally allows the app to be smarter.
Avoiding work for its clinical user and
thereby increasing the attractiveness of using the app.